John Barry who's been calling some
excellent action on ESPN radio he's
calling Warriors Trail Blazers series on
ESPN ESPN rating along so I'm Adam Amin
and he's here on the Richards and show
how are you John
are you serious no I'm hanging in there
man I'm hanging in there where do you
want to start I'll give you dealer's
choice the Warriors up three Oh what
happened last night in Toronto or what
went down with Magic Johnson today John
which which one leaps out at you of out
of out of all three well I was thinking
Brooks kept kept his Heisman on his
girlfriend if you want to do that well
John I mean that's that ones normally
tough to come back from I'll tell you
that but it looks like it was a good day
for Brooks all right why would she want
to risk was she want to kiss him his
breath has got a brutal after what he
went through 18 holes of that maybe she
just wanted to just give him something
for good luck John maybe there's she's
just in love it could be just as simple
as that I don't want to blame her here
it was the kiss was before the night's
around no she try yeah before the round
there he's arriving and then you know
after the window was all is all peaches
and cream it was fantastic
I thought it was after I thought you
were talking about no sir no let's get
to the yeah okay so let's let's start
let's start with the Bucks and the
Raptors what do you take out of that the
fact that the Raptors have the gumption
to stick their foot in the ground and
come up with a must win or Kawhi looks
banged up and that might be a problem
moving forward for everybody what do you
have for me John yeah I mean gosh Hawaii
look like he was laboring big time I
mean can he bounce back you know less
than 48 hours later to get in another
must-win when you go down to oh you know
you got to win the next two you go home
if you go down 3-1 certainly your backs
against the wall so physically can he be
okay but man has he been awesome in the
playoffs and a lot of credit to Toronto
did some different things guarding the
honest
certainly have a couple of double teams
a lot more
Lenard guarding him but can you ask why
- go get 30-plus and guard Yanis again
tomorrow
that's an awfully tall tall task well
it's not just that - if they somehow get
past the Bucs how the heck are they
gonna get past the team that you're
seeing right there in front of you where
does this rank and the impressive
impressiveness meter what you're seeing
out of the Warriors - no ranch on yeah
well it's uh you know Steph Curry's
obviously stepped up he's got thirty
five plus in the last three games was
obviously at that 33 against Houston to
close them out in Game six you know
these guys are still pretty good they
want a championship before Kevin Durant
got here this bench has been much
maligned basically because they don't
get a whole lot of opportunity now
they're getting the opportunity and each
guy is making an impact draymond greens
playing the best basketball I think of
his life he was incredible in Game three
and look this is a championship team and
they know they know what it takes and
they've outscored the Blazers by like 13
in Game one 11 in Game two or 18 in Game
two and 21 in Game three in the second
half of games
it's incredible what they've been able
to do you just you marvel that what
we're seeing here in this five-year run
one of the great teams of all time John
Berry here on the Rich Eisen show I just
I mean which one is it impressing you
the most which player I I can't get
enough of what draymond Green is doing
John but I mean you're the one eye
balling it up close I mean which one or
or is it Kerr I mean which which one is
the most impressive out of this last run
since Durant's calf gave way and Game
five against the Rockets yeah you know
it's tough because so many guys have
been great but to me you know Steph
Curry is the longest
he's the system and when the Kevin
Durant's there it's still about Steph
Curry this guy is a dynamic player I
mean we just we've never seen a guy
the way he plays and his ability to
shoot the ball from 30-plus feet he
creates everything that the Warriors do
is the pace the space
he makes life easier for every other
player on the team when he's making
shots from where he's making that makes
it easier for draymond Green that makes
it easier for klay Thompson and these
other guys so to me it's about Stefan
you know steps up with the 33 points in
the second half of Game six against
Houston and he's just crushing the
Portland here with 35 plus he's been
remarkable so which team I'm assuming I
know the answer but I'll ask anyway
which team would give the Warriors the
toughest run to prevent them from going
back to back to back I don't know I
think Milwaukee's probably just a little
more scoring 3-point shooting you know
with Andre Iguodala being banged up we
don't know his status tonight he's we
don't know if he's going to go if he
were to be down if Kevin Durant stays
out which no one really knows they don't
have a whole lot of options that are
gonna be able to guard key Yanis and ten
ikuko so you know Milwaukee is dangerous
I think they're gonna bounce back and
win this series against Toronto and I
should it'd be a hell of a final it's
gonna be interesting to see the
Milwaukee Bucks playing in the NBA
Finals yeah yeah I know I mean is there
any sign of boogie at all or that that's
that ship sailed do you think boogie
cousins yeah you know they say he's
falling along that Brant so he's been
doing some more on the court stuff
Durant hasn't even been on the court you
know I don't know but I don't even know
how big a factor that is for this
warrior team I know he wouldn't have
played very much against Houston with
the way they play so small you know
Milwaukee does have Brook Lopez but he's
primarily a perimeter player shoots a
lot of three-point shots so I don't know
how much DeMarcus Cousins could factor
into this team whether he'd be healthy
or not John Barry here from the
worldwide leader in sports ESPN amidst
the Conference Finals and then today on
first take on ESPN
Magic Johnson took to the microphone and
really laid waste quite frankly to rob
polenka the rest of the front office
that Jeannie boss put together along
with that that he departed from just a
couple of weeks ago I'm wondering what
you you think of some of the quotes that
came out of it
John yeah just saying I mean he
certainly didn't hold back and we all
know it's been a dysfunctional couple of
months for LA and I was surprised that
magic was so candid and clearly felt
like stuff was going on behind his back
he didn't have the type of power that he
he thought that he was going to garner
and man they got they got some serious
issues going on there I know I mean how
do they put it back together before July
for our stuff I mean how do they put it
well I I don't know I mean who would
other star player wants to come play
with LeBron I just you know maybe
they're not going to talk about it but I
just don't see how that's going to be
you know in the problem now you have
LeBron three more years and if you bring
in the type of players that you have to
bring in with LeBron to try to win in
those three years what happens when
LeBron is gone you're left with a group
of players that that that's not going to
be good enough so I don't know I mean I
know Jeff Van Gundy said a while back
trading LeBron James that might be the
best thing for the LA Lakers you know
why if I'm LeBron again you know
speaking for for number 23 as I'm sure
he really would not appreciate but we'd
have a problem and I definitely know
that I'll tell you that I'm a one tool
player I'm a half tool player yeah if
that and that might be talking up my
game
I want out I look around the landscape
and I try and figure out who can afford
me and where I can go with these final
three three seasons you know I walk into
Jeannie boss's office and say what is
happening
and if not then let's try and
accommodate everybody you love the young
players here clearly you know we we
tried our best there's no way that David
Griffin's gonna I don't care about the
fourth overall selection it doesn't seem
to me that David Griffin's gonna grant
Rob palinka the wish that Dell Demps
according to magic just totally screwed
him over by talking publicly about
everything and sabotage the rest of that
locker room I mean wouldn't you want to
get out if you're LeBron just based
again on just what we're seeing from the
outside out well yeah
but I think a lot of this was la is what
he wanted you know he was in he's in
Hollywood you know and that's something
he's thought post career it's something
that's important to him I don't think
this was a anywhere close to 100%
decision basketball-wise to go to LA it
made no sense with you look at the
roster you see what they brought in over
last summer he had to know what was
going on I think he was hoping that they
could get things fixed a lot quicker and
it would be this summer maybe you know
sacrificing last year but it's still a
long ways away and what did you and
sorry yeah I just think it's a lady
wanted rich you know and I think that's
more than the basketball look he's
entitled to that the guy went to the
finals what eight straight years yeah
you want a title for Cleveland and the
guy's one of the Great's of all time so
if that's a decision he wants to make
and then he's entitled to that what did
you think last one for you John then
about the the draft lottery coming out
of it do you do like the fact that it
was so mixed up that the odds to win
first overall or get in the top four
seemed much more even or flatter do you
do you like that sort of thing or the
fact that that this now adds more
difficulty for the worst teams to get
better yeah no I think it's good you
know I think that'll help with the
tanking I think that's what the top
three teams none of them got in the
bottom third I guess New York was the
only one that got third so yeah yeah I'm
okay with that I just hope you know Zion
doesn't have a power play and
I'm not going to play in New Orleans and
we have some sort of bass I hope he goes
there and maybe Anthony Davis decides to
stay since ion could come on board who
knows all right John thanks for the time
man enjoy tonight's game and we'll chat
with you during the during the finals
okay but don't run anymore 40s anytime
soon it's not I have no next time you
see me running we'll be in February of
next year
excellent thanks buddy you take care of
yourself that's John Bowring here for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app